le premier ministre justin trudeau lui
réitère plus tôt son intention de mettre
fin à la participation canadienne à ses
frappes aériennes en série certains
remettent en cause cette intention
alors le canada devrait-il revenir sur
cette décision
j'accueille le major général à la
retraite terry liston se distinguent
bonsoir bonsoir
alors le président françois hollande on
l'a entendu tout à leur parle de
déclaration de guerre il dit qu'il faut
intensifier les frappes aériennes
augmenter ses frappes
est ce que la décision du gouvernement
canadien peut tenir dans ces
circonstances dans ce nouveau contexte
avec les attentats de paris
je crois que oui mais surtout si on
regarde pourquoi la france a agi comme
ça un peu comme pourquoi george bush
après les frappes de 9,11 là pourquoi il
s'est attaqué de l'otan - pourquoi il a
attaqué l'afghanistan
c'est le besoin des chefs politiques
doctel quelque chose de faire quelque
chose méchant avec les gens qui ont fait
ça alors je dis mais regardons l'aspect
militaire est-ce que les frappes que les
français font actuellement est ce que ce
genre de situation stratégique sur le
terrain je pense que ça change pas grand
chose mais 7,9 à et de l'image du
président chez lui c'est pas efficaces
contre le groupe armé islamique
mais est-ce que c'est efficace et
dépenser quoi votre objectif ça va mais
ça va être une nuisance pour eux on dit
même que depuis que les frais pour
commencer il ya vingt mille membres de
l'êta il a mais qui ont été tués
mais ils ont pu les remplacer avec le
recrutement
ils n'ont pas perdu beaucoup de terrain
toutes les villes qu'ils ont pris qu'ils
ont capturé dans les dernières quelques
années il les tire bien faire mais que
le canada se retire maintenant après ces
attaques très meurtrière à paris est-ce
que c'est pas comme si le canada
abandonnés au fond la coalition
internationale moment très crucial
lequel john cho lee qui au port du coup
du du combat la canada retire ses avions
c'est une politique du gouvernement mais
voit en même temps on dit on reste on va
fournir les instructeurs qui vont aider
les les kurdes dans le nord de l'irak
principalement ça c'est pas encore
annoncé officiellement par ailleurs on
vous cherchez du jour c'est des gens
reconnus et acceptés mais on sait entre
les lignes que une mission de
d'instruction comme avec les américains
ge a plus augmenté puis devenu un peu le
plus audacieux
maintenant je les ai bien qu'un se
retrouve maintenant des soldats
américains se retrouvent aux côtés des
kurdes sur le terrain donc ce jugement
d'un jury qui ont dans la branche qu'ils
font dans le nord de l'irak mais retiré
les avions quand même au moment où
justement françois hollande dit il faut
intensifier les frappes aériennes
oui mais il franchit pas comme un
militaire il parle simplement comme un
politicien qui doit réagir parce que le
peuple français est franche et alors il
faut faire quelque chose
les les frappes aériennes
l'aviation stratégique dans l'histoire
est encore aujourd'hui ne peut pas
gagner des campagnes ils ont mais en
d'autres même sont habilitées de
détruire
l'infrastructure est essentielle du pays
est ce que vous dites que finalement la
contribution canadienne en ce moment
qu'on se retire qu'on continue ça change
pas grand chose à la mission
non j'en viens parce que imaginer les
américains seule super puissance du
monde il personne qui marche aura
d'autres ils ont la force aérienne le
plus puissante au monde
est ce que nos 6 msv
lorsqu'on retire ça est-ce que ça va
affecter la puissance américaine
mais non mais toute cette puissance
aérienne a quand même réussi comme de
peut-être
retarder un peu la vence de l'état
islamique dans le désert
sakho nuisances dans le sens caen paris
sont hébergés parmi la population civile
pour éviter les frappes aériennes dans
des baraques et jouent ils ont changé de
tactique pour éviter ces frappes là mais
le ferai ce que le terrain qu'ils ont
pris ils retiennent toujours le
recrutement continue
puis la seule chose qui va changer 107
une campagne où seuls par une désormais
très important mais pour le moment il ya
aucun pays qui veut vraiment se lancer
là dedans mais une part du jeu pays
arabes
c'est vrai célestin merci beaucoup plus
dur